spar dir dein Geld ab heute kannst du
Rahmen zu Hause essen Alter diese Brühe
und all das in unter 30 Minuten zu
allererst hackanbraten ordentlich
andrücken und Knallgas in einen weiteren
Topf geben wir Butter und Mais einfach
bei mittlerer Hitze stehen lassen jetzt
bloschieren wir packchoy und wenden das
Fleisch wenn es nicht so dunkel ist
machst du was falsch jetzt holen wir das
Hack raus Schlückchen Öl in den Topf und
Schalotten hinterher Eier in Topf Deckel
drauf und für 8 Minuten kochen dann
Knoblauch ingwa und ein bisschen Zucker
als nächstes Misopaste das hier ist
purer Geschmack und den löschen wir
jetzt mit Brühe ab jetzt geben wir auch
unser Hack wieder dazu lassen alles warm
werden wer mag noch ein Paket daschi
meist ist fertig wenn die Butter braun
ist starten wir mit der Brühe als
nächstes die Nudeln m geil es folgt
unser Ei das Ei legen wir hinein etwas
von unserem gebräunten Mais ein bisschen
Sesam Pack choy Frühlingszwiebeln und in
die Mitte etwas Chiliöl evil fertig sind
unsere Rahmen